[Music]
part motorcycle parked off carpark
futuristic podmobile this three-wheeled
concept car was enough to pull a handful
of US lawmakers away from the business
of legislating for a test drive
why the Toyota has a big plant in my
district in southwest Indiana and
Princeton and I wanted to see what the
eye road can do because I think there's
some potential opportunity or it
especially in urban settings I was
fascinated by it so I test drove it
today and it was fun me too iota I rode
the concept car that debuted at the 2013
Geneva Auto Show this two-seater is
powered by a lithium ion battery giving
it about 30 miles per charge the tops
out at about 28 miles per hour it's not
yet approved for u.s. roads but what is
already pitching it is a perfect car for
city dwellers well we're seeing these
vehicles really fit into a
transportation network where they can be
shared between users and play a role
between mass transportation such as
trains or bus systems so why Washington
well when you've got a new technology
and you're considering whether to take
it to u.s. roads might as well show it
off to the nation's decision-makers the
eye road employs what the carmaker calls
active lean a system that uses a set of
onboard computers to counterbalance
centrifugal force when the vehicle turns
oh it's kind of fun we're frankly
testing to see what public reaction is
and what do people think of this is
there actually a market for such a
vehicle in the United States and how did
the show go over compared to some floor
debates and door hearings
Oh way more exciting way more say
usually when you have fast objects
coming at you it's not an informal
automobile out here in DC
it's like